hassane kouyaté pourquoi partez vous en
faites chez moi on dit quitte les choses
avant que les choses ne tout petit
voilà je j'ai estimé que j'ai fait tout
ce que je pouvais pour développer ce
projet et qu' il était temps que
d'autres personnes continuent à mettre
toutes nos idées d'autres énergies et
puis aussi personnellement j'avais aussi
besoin d'aller vers d'autres challenges
quand on dit on et directeur d'un projet
comme celui-là on engage aussi de
personnes autour sa famille et aussi
pour le développement des membres de ma
famille il était aussi important que nos
partenaires d'autres horizons
dans quel état d'esprit partie vous
alors je pars avec un sentiment de
fierté
je suis fier de l'implication que j'ai
j'ai apportés à ce projet je me suis
impliqué à 120 pour ça je suis fier de
ce qui a été fait avec mes collègues
donc c'est l'occasion pour moi de leur
remercier le remercier leur engagement
leur travail et leur dévouement pour la
culture et pour leur pays mais je pars
aussi avec aucun des sentiments parce
que il faut le dire il ya eu des
péripéties mais dans chaque action et
activités humaines il ya des ja du pouls
et du contrat du bien du mauvais c'est
comme le jour et la nuit
le bilan que vous faites est donc un
bilan satisfaisant est satisfait c'est
un mot un peu trop pour moi je parce que
je pense que on pouvait encore mieux
faire on vous dira que voilà on peut
toujours mieux faire c'est vrai mais moi
je pense que on a bien travaillé on a eu
des résultats positifs mais
les résultats ne sont pas allés au
jusqu'où je pourrais espérer qu'il soit
ce territoire est un territoire qu un
potentiel énorme vraiment énorme énorme
d'abord de par son histoire et l'homme
donc de par sa culture énorme ne pas sa
position géographique et 12 n'ont pas
les femmes et les hommes qui l'habitent
et puis ces territoires à une histoire
culturelle artistique très forte
on a posé des actes essentiels aux au
niveau de l'accompagnement au niveau de
la formation et au niveau de la création
la diffusion qui peuvent être des bases
pour un développement pour que ça aille
davantage plus haut plus loin je pense
qu'ils y seraient nécessaires quand même
de s'asseoir avoir une étape de
réflexion réellement vous pensez à des
états généraux des états généraux de la
culture
en fait les états généraux ont toujours
fait mal mais quand c'est bien fait il
ya toujours 11
on sent toujours grandi des états
généraux on sort toujours grandi de deux
d'une réflexion il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui de mon point de vue que la
martinique fait état des lieux j'ai cru
comprendre que c'est dans les tuyaux de
des pouvoirs en place
quelles ont été vos difficultés la plus
grande difficulté pour moi était de
cette fusion la d'abord visionné le mac
qui est international et la très longue
et interdépartementale ces deux
structures devaient travailler pour la
culture est pour le peuple et les
artistes martiniquais mais les voies et
les moyens pour y parvenir
tu es différent le cahier des charges
n'était pas les mêmes donc fusionner ces
deux structures
ça n'a pas été évident ça n'a pas été
évident du point de vue
des collègues d'abord qui avait c'est
pour certains 30 ans de carrière dans
une ou l'autre si tu leur dis qu'il
fallait aller vers autre chose
crier autre chose et mutualiser les
forces et laisser certaines habitudes
aller vers d'autres ça ce n'était pas
évident il y avait aussi la difficulté
pour les artistes locaux de comprendre
cette fusion de deux de comprendre que
les structures n'étaient plus les mêmes
que l'émission n'était plus le même et
qui surtout que le cadre juridique
n'étaient plus les mêmes et je sais pas
faute d'avoir essayé de communiquer
peut-être qu'on a mal communiqué
là-dessus certainement s'il ya des
incompréhensions
il y avait un problème de communication
par moments je vais parler de ça aussi
il y avait aussi de la mauvaise foi
ensuite il y avait quand même une fois
le dire
il s'était même is d'une c'est dans sept
groupes d'artistes sur ces outils là
c'était des artistes qui étaient souvent
là et qu'il y avait certaines conditions
sauf que la mission de l'est pcc et de
la scène nationale que moi j'avais
c'était de réagir
tout ça parce que la moyenne d'âge quand
même deux des artistes du spectacle
vivant était qu un de 45 à 48 ans sur le
territoire contre 22 sur le territoire
national c'est donc s'ils avaient
quelque chose quand même pour la relève
pour le sud du pays et avaient des
questions à se poser là dessus
le fait de vouloir régénérer ce paysage
culturel artistique bien sûr que ça peut
poser des problèmes à ceux qui étaient
assis qu'il y avait certains privilèges
entre guillemets puisque voilà c'était
c'est ça devrait des situations durante
sur un territoire et donc bousculer ces
situations bien sûr que ça ça peut
déranger
ça peut perturber d'autres personnes
moi j'aurais voulu que de la réaction de
certains artistes y réagissent à sa part
leur travail par leurs propositions
artistiques
je crois que si j'ai toujours dit un
artiste quand si sa proposition
artistique est forte
c'est un minimum mais un minimum de
politique culturelle sur le territoire
même si il est pur nord où je sais pas
chez les pygmées dans un trou de souris
on est là le chercher donc je dis c'est
souvent facile de dire est ce la faute
de l'autre et c'est celle des problèmes
aussi que je rencontre si c'était toi on
accuse souvent l'autre nôtre c'est pas
forcément sur les qui vient d'ailleurs
ça commence par le collègue qui est le
ski est aussi metteur en scène et
chorégraphe qui est musicien
oui c'est sa faute il a toujours sa
l'huile à moi j'ai pas ça on travaille
souvent par comparaison au lieu de we
all et que l'autre soit une émulation
l'autre devient souvent un frein
malheureusement même un adversaire
moi j'ai appris je viens d'un pays où
nos aînés qui ont percé sous loue
c'était des exemples étaient de
l'humiliation
on voulait être en tous cas me manque
comme peu sinon les dépasser mais alain
respectant pas ce que c'était c'était
des guides bain et j'ai l'impression
je dis bien l'impression parce qu'au
bout de quatre ans peut pas prétendre
connaître un pays un peuple mais j'ai
l'impression par rapport aux gens que
j'ai fréquentés et dans le cadre de mon
travail mais ça c'était un problème
c'est que la halle les ya très peu
d'émulation
mais à beaucoup d'adversité et est la
preuve sur ce territoire j'ai pas vu de
vrais collectif d'artistes
je suis étonné du manque de
mutualisation des forces du manque de
mutualisation des connaissances sur ce
territoire
parce que il n'est pas gras dans la
réalité mais
je suis déçu certains territoires sur
lesquels je travaille et où il ya deux
fois 15 à 20 millions d'habitants
mais les artistes on trouve une
nécessité de travailler ensemble mais
très très très très très très forte
on pense que travailler ensemble ça
diminue la force des noms ça nous
renforce au contraire sur ce territoire
pour moi c'était aussi un frein pour le
développement parce que plus les et il y
avait je sentais moins de l'adversité
entre artix plus il a l'air à une
émulation qui allait encore aider le pcc
tropiques atrium pouvoir accompagner le
mieux possible les artistes parlez nous
un peu de votre relation avec le
politique tropiques
atrium a eu aucun problème avec les
collectivités qui se sont succédé au
contraire il ya eu une bienveillance il
faut le dire avec l'équipe qui m'a fait
venir et qui m'a donné les moyens
jeudi les moyens parce qu'il ya eu des
travaux de bâtiment c'était important
il ya eu aussi l'augmentation du budget
pour aller vers les missions qui m'ont
assignés qui m'ont demandé de m'aider et
l'équipe qui est venu avec la 7e c'était
pareil a vraiment soutenu le projet à
continuer à réfléchir à développer le
projet avec avec moi là dessus
vraiment et du côté de l'état pareil je
dirais que les mois les pc ces tropiques
atrium nous avons profité de de vent
favorable aussi bien au niveau de
collectivités territoriales et de l'état
donc de la date mais comme j'ai dit on
peut toujours améliorer les choses
et le deuxième point du dj qui j'allais
intervenu sous deux plans le deuxième
point est celui qui ne concerne pas
directement tropez quatrième c'est ça
n'engage que moi c'est en tant que
experts en bim puisque j'ai fait des
audits pour des états pour les pays pour
les villes ailleurs sur les politiques
structurelles ne trouve que sur le
territoire
aujourd'hui comme je dis faut
diagnostiquer les choses pour pouvoir
soigner vos diagnostics et dans les
choses évidentes pour le mans qui me
semble évidente c'est la formation
c'est un des rares territoires que j'ai
vu qui a fourni autant d'artistes
autant de possibilités culturelles
artistiques qui n'a pas le candidat pas
de conservatoire
par exemple un conservateur c'est pas la
panacée des propos politiques qui ne
sais pas ce que je dis c'est bel est un
président mais qui n'a pas d'école
supérieure à part le plan puisse
caraïbes un désert et qui a pas d'école
supérieure en tout cas tenu par les
collectivités territoires par l'état
pour pour l'éventualité de la
professionnalisation des gens qui
veulent faire ce métier le troisième
point c'est les politiques des
collectivités
depuis je parle sur le territoire les
communes les communautés d'agglo et
c'est là je ne je n'ai pas de visibilité
réelle sur les politiques culturelles
des communes et ni des communautés
d'agglo
je ne connais pas réellement peut-être
ça existe je dis je ne connais pas si
j'en prenais pas ça veut dire aussi que
c'est pas visible que donc il ya une
différence quelque part il faut il ne
faut pas oublier que l'art et la culture
c'est le premier vecteur de
développement d'une société
on se trompe de cible quand on parle de
développement
et les chiffres sont éloquents c'est la
culture c'est le seul domaine
quand tu mets de l'argent je suis que
tous les corps de métier passe par là
même le fisc
mais la douane en parlant de des taxis
des transportent des hôteliers de ceux
qui vendent la nourriture
donnez nous nos soeurs nos maîtres qui
vend des pistaches sortie trouve quelque
chose dans cette politique dont je parle
de des communes des communautés d'agglo
etc
ça me fait parler des lieux de travail
seulement même pas que démonstration il
ya tellement sur ce territoire de lieux
fermés de bâtiments fermés et qui est
qui ont pas besoin de beaucoup beaucoup
de moyens pour les rénover et mettre à
la disposition de la création la
créativité pour que l'art et la culture
puisse être développé
il faut aussi donner l'espace
d'expression aux artistes
que souhaitez vous à votre successeur
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de courage
parce que c'est du courage il ya
beaucoup de chantiers comme j'ai dit on
a beaucoup travaillé mais ce que nous
nous avons fait n'est qu'une goutte
d'eau dans l'océan des possibles affaire
donc encore beaucoup de travail mais je
vous souhaite beaucoup de chance et je
souhaite qu'ils aient de la sérénité
autour de lui puis y ait de la patience
autour de lui qu'on le laisse travailler
et enfin qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter bonne chance
et puis à vous aussi bonne chance aussi